bien bonjour à toutes et à tous je
voudrais avec mes amis guillaume les de
guillaume évoqué deux sujets importants
pour les républicains cette semaine
premier sujet concerne une question
d'actualité de fond très importante
philosophiquement qui est la question du
rsa et de l'initiative qui a été prise
par notre ami eric straumann président
du conseil départemental du haut rhin et
qui consiste en échange du maintien du
rsa de demander aux allocataires un
engagement de sept heures deux
engagements auprès d'associations
nous sommes très favorables à cette
initiative
pour deux raisons l'une philosophique et
nicolas sarkozy avait eu l'occasion
pendant son quinquennat
et au moment de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 de faire ses
propositions
philosophiquement les républicains c'est
le parti des droits et des devoirs et
nous considérons qui ne doit pas y avoir
d'allocations dette sans engagement sans
retour de la part de la locataire ce
sont les droits et les devoirs
la contrepartie c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous encourageons eric
straumann dans cette logique
la deuxième raison pour laquelle nous
sommes favorables c'est aussi une raison
liée à l'actualité
le gouvernement assèche les finances des
départements
chaque jour c'est soit un nouveau
transfert de compétences soit une
augmentation d'allocations décidée
unilatéralement par l'état qui fait
payer la facture par les départements je
vous donne un exemple concernant le rsa
en 2009 le financement du rsa qui est
payé par les départements étaient
financés à hauteur de 90% par les
transferts de l'état
ce niveau est aujourd'hui à 60%
donc ça veut dire que les décisions de
l'état du gouvernement aujourd'hui
impacte directement les départements qui
fuit
hans e même sur leurs propres budgets
sur leurs ressources à hauteur de 40%
ce sont les deux raisons très importante
pour lequel les républicains encouragent
cette initiative et soutiennent
fortement eric straumann deuxième
élément important plus politique avant
de passer la parole à nos deux porte
parole elle concerne l'événement de la
semaine sur le plan politique pour les
républicains qui est l'organisation de
notre conseil national
c'est un événement très important
pourquoi parce que c'est le nouveau
parlement du parti qui se réunit un
nouveau parlement avec de nouvelles
règles d'élection plus démocratique plus
proche du terrain
je rappelle que siégeront samedi des
présidents de fédérations qui ont été
élus directement par les militants
suffrage direct
je rappelle que parmi les conseillers
nationaux ont été élus dimanche dernier
et de dimanche d'avant il y à une partie
qui était réservé aux nouveaux adhérents
aux jeunes donc c'est un conseil
national qui a été totalement renouvelée
qui siègera samedi prochain l'objectif
c'est qu'on puisse avoir un grand et
beau débat sur la ligne politique
souvenez vous ces derniers mois il ya eu
à plusieurs reprises des personnalités
importantes du mouvement qui se sont
exprimés en disant il faut que nous
ayons un débat sur la ligne nous allons
avoir ce débat ce week end sur la ligne
politique du parti
ce sera un débat très interactif
l'objectif c'est de donner la parole aux
forces vives du mouvement de donner la
parole à ses cadres
ceux qui reviennent des fédérations ceux
qui ont été candidats des élections à
ceux qui incarnent un peu cette vitalité
du parti
donc ces deux jours seront organisés de
manière très interactive avec l'objectif
de débattre sur le fond de la ligne du
mouvement
c'est important avant d'engager les
échéances de 2010
voilà les deux sujets que je voulais
aborder rapidement avec vous je pourrai
répondre tout à l'heure à vos questions
si vous en avez et puis je vais
peut-être céder la parole à
guillaume pour aborder une autre
actualité criante qui était notamment le
réunion du front national ce week-end
merci luc bonjour à tous quelques mots
pour faire la transition par rapport à
ce que vient d'exprimer très justement
luxure notre conseil national nous notre
ambition le week-end prochain c'est
importé à travers la définition de la
ligne du parti de donner du sens à
l'engagement politique
al'inverse de ce qui s'est passé le
week-end et au parti socialiste et au
front national dont les différents
séminaires aux conseils nationaux sur
plutôt vide et creux
le parti socialiste a annoncé à priori
qu'il n'y aurait pas de programme ou de
projets pour 2017 mais simplement des
cahiers de la présidentielle donc on
s'en fout on sent bien le le flou
artistique qui règne au sein du parti
socialiste sur les 1000 lignes possibles
et imaginables on le voit d'ailleurs à
travers toutes les interventions
politiques et médiatiques des uns et des
autres et puis de l'autre côté
le séminaire du front national dont on
nous a parlé des semaines et des
semaines durant sur une potentielle
révolution sur les idées et qui finit
par ne rien donner
comme on dit là la montagne a accouché
d'une souris au plus tôt d'un tout petit
mulot on le voit sur toutes les
thématiques on devait il devait remettre
en cause la sortie de l'euro préciser
leur position sur les 35 heures sur la
retraite à 60 ans sur le smic et les
différentes interventions de la soirée
hier démontre que rien n'a bougé et que
rien n'a changé et que par conséquent
comme nous l'avons dit que nous disons
avec force ce matin le front national
reste le parti du constat le parti
socialiste le parti de l'échec et que la
grande responsabilité qui est celle des
républicains et de devenir d'incarner
tout au long de l'année 2016 et 2017 le
grand parti des solutions des solutions
crédibles concrètes courageuse aux
problèmes que rencontrent nos
concitoyens ça nous amène à l'une des
polémiques des dernières heures ou ou du
week end à travers ce qu'il s'est passé
akalé qu'on appelle la sphère piquemal
nous notre position est claire il est
évidemment hors de question de soutenir
le principe d'une manifestation
interdite
nous sommes attachés à l'état de droit
mais vous livrez double réflexion
d'abord les français et nous avec eux
n'en peuvent plus du deux poids deux
mesures
cette impression permanente d'impunité
que ce soit pour les no borders qui
peuvent manifester semaine après semaine
taguée la statue du général de gaulle
100 de conséquences lourdes
ce fut la même chose quand on écoute le
maire socialiste de rennes
ces dernières heures qui dénoncent
l'incapacité de l'état à intervenir avec
force après le un centre ville saccagée
quand on voit les images quand on voit
les comptes rendus dans la presse
quotidienne régionale ce matin ce qui
s'est passé à rennes est absolument
inacceptable
mais il ya bien plus grave que cela
encore c'est que à calais tout cela est
la conséquence d'une incurie de l'état
d'une loi de la jungle qui a remplacé la
loi de la république et nous le disons
on nous parle depuis de longues semaines
de l'état d'urgence
la vérité c'est qu'à calais comme
ailleurs il y a urgence d'un état et que
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de rétablir
l'autorité de l'état dans tous les
domaines et non plus de gesticuler de
commenter d'annoncé monsieur cazeneuve
s'est rendu à plusieurs reprises
reprises sur place rien ne s'est passé
monsieur hollande ne s'est toujours pas
rendu
rien ne se passe et l'état l'ensemble du
gouvernement est incapable de présenter
des propositions solides et constructive
on est dans une situation apocalyptique
à calais il suffit d'écouter
citoyens les commerçants les
entrepreneurs les élus locaux qui n'en
peuvent plus de voir un état aux abonnés
absents et donc nous avons évidemment
tout au long des dernières semaines fait
un certain nombre de propositions
je pense à guillaume larrivé eric ciotti
sur notre capacité à réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'état dissoudre par
exemple les associations d'extrême
gauche
expulsé celles et ceux qui n'ont rien à
faire sur le territoire national enfin
repenser refonder la construction
européenne autour de l'idée de frontière
européenne pour répondre à l'afflux
massif à l' angoisse des calaisiens et à
l'angoissé des peuples européens car
aujourd'hui l'europe et la france par
est incapable de régler la grande
question des migrations et dans le
prolongement de ce qui était évoqué tout
à l'heure le discours de villepin tout
la campagne de 2012 la question centrale
des frontières qui avait évoqué nicolas
sarkozy sous les attaques caricaturales
à l'époque tout cela devient comme une
évidence
aujourd'hui on ne réglera pas cette
question si on ne prend pas en compte la
question centrale des frontières et tant
d'autres comme une coalition
internationale ou d'autres sujets gilles
guillaume
merci bonjour à tous quelques mots sur
le débat parlementaire cette semaine qui
concerne comme vous le savez pour deux
cas je pense que ça ne vous a pas
échappé
le projet de loi de révision
constitutionnelle voudrais ici rappeler
un principe la suite de ce que vient de
dire guillaume pelletier nous les
républicains nous revendiquons le
principe selon lequel l'état de droit
doit être fort
si l'état de droit est faible il n'est
plus l'état
il n'y a plus de droit c'est la loi de
la jungle qui l'emportent à rennes à
calais ou à paris l'état de droit doit
être fort et nous avons le devoir de
renforcer l'état de droit pour vaincre
ces terroristes islamistes qui veulent
nous détruire
c'est ça
l'idée force l'idée majeure ça suppose
avant même d'évoquer les questions
constitutionnelles
ça suppose d'abord de combler un certain
nombre de failles opérationnel dans la
lutte antiterroriste et c'est la raison
pour laquelle les députés républicains
nous créons cette semaine à l'assemblée
nationale une commission d' enquête sur
la manière dont le gouvernement a ou n'a
pas géré la menace terroriste depuis
janvier 2015
nous installerons demain mardi à
l'assemblée cette commission denquête
sous la présidence de georges fenech des
failles opérationnels doivent être
comblées deuxièmement des instruments
juridiques nouveaux doivent être
adoptées et nous ne cesserons pas nous
les députés républicains avec nos
collègues sénateurs d'appeler le
gouvernement à rompre avec le
désarmement pénale qu'il a engagé depuis
quatre ans car tout est lié
l'explosion de la délinquance de droit
commun est évidemment liée à certains
aspects de la mouvance terroriste et
nous appelons le gouvernement à rompre
avec ce désarmement pénale car engagé
cas conduit l'ancienne garde des sceaux
pendant quatre ans troisièmement nous
sommes convaincus qu'une vraie stratégie
diplomatique et militaire doit être de
toute urgence défini redéfinit pour
vaincre d'âge dans la zone irako
syrienne
voilà les trois urgences le président de
la république lui a choisi il y a
maintenant près de trois mois à
versailles de nous soumettre un projet
de loi de révision constitutionnelle
lorsque
l'avons entendu à versailles nous avons
eu le sentiment que sur la question de
la nationalité
le président françois hollande s'est
rallié au fond à la position qui avait
exprimé par le président nicolas sarkozy
lors de son discours de grenoble en 2010
position que les députés républicains
nous avons affirmé réaffirmé depuis
quatre ans avec de très nombreuses
propositions de loi qu'ils avaient
toutes été rejetées d'un revers de main
par le gouvernement socialiste
depuis trois mois les tergiversations
les hésitations les fluctuations
internes à la majorité socialiste ont
produit de la confusion
je pars faire le film que chacun a à
l'esprit mais on a quand même assisté à
un festival assez surréaliste quand même
le discours de versailles immédiatement
contredit par le garde des sceaux de
l'époque puis le premier ministre qui
contredit le garde des sceaux qui
réaffirme une position puis diverses
versions 4 5 6 on a du mal à les compter
qu'ils ne sont pas un facteur de
clarification du débat plus il ya de
confusion à gauche et au sein de
gouvernements plus nous réaffirmons ici
aux républicains une conviction
nous n'avons pas à nous excuser de
penser que les français qui tuent des
français parce qu'ils sont français ne
mérite pas d'être français les français
qui tue et des français parce qu'ils
sont français ne mérite pas d'être
français il exclut eux mêmes de la
communauté nationale et la république
française a le devoir de le constater en
leur retirant la nationalité française
et en les expulsant du territoire
national ce principe
cette conviction c'est celle de
l'ensemble des républicains
maintenant le débat parlementaire se
poursuit 7
rémy dit même nous aurons pour la
première fois dans l'hémicycle
en tout cas nous le souhaitons nous
aimerions la voie pour la première fois
l'amendement définitif en tout cas on
imagine du gouvernement la discussion va
donc se poursuivre cet après midi va se
poursuivre cette nuit
demain matin les députés républicains se
réuniront sous la présidence de
christian jacob et nous auront
naturellement une discussion au sein du
groupe avant d'avoir mercredi un vote
dans l'hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale
sachant que nous avons aussi comme vous
le savez évidemment une discussion qui
se fera ensuite au sénat
nous ne dévierons pas d'une ligne droite
qui est celle de la défense de la france
et des français